See what I did there?
What's up global citizens? Today we are learning English
with Pixar-Disney's animation Incredibles 2.
You'll learn lots of business-related vocabulary
you can start using right now
while understanding a bit more of the American lifestyle.
But in case you are new here, the scenes
we chose have NO spoilers.
You will watch two scenes from the movie, learn the vocabulary
and then have the chance to watch it again
without the subtitles with a few quiz questions.
Because that's what we do here at Learn English with TV.
Three times a week we help you understand fast English
without getting lost, without missing the jokes, and
without subtitles, just like Hamid
who says that "Our channel is
an effective way to learn english."
If you enjoy learning with your favorite movies and
TV series, don’t forget to give us a thumbs up
and also, check out our Disney playlist where you’ll find lessons with Soul, Up, Tangled and so many more great movies!
Just click the link in the description below!
Let's get started with the lesson!
If you are looking into expanding your network,
to feel more confident to speak English,
and connect with people from all around the globe, then I want to tell you you can do it all with just the touch of a button!
We built the RealLife App so that you can connect to other
English learners from around the world
and practice your speaking while discovering other cultures in fun and dynamic way, through short conversations.
It is like your virtual passport to the world! In addition to that,
you can improve your comprehension with real life native conversations by following a transcription of our Podcast.
You will understand 100% and
never forget the most important vocabulary.
So download it now by clicking the
link down in the description below
or search for the RealLife English App in the
Apple App Store or Google Play Store.
I look forward to seeing you there!
If you chose "B" then you are correct!
I hope you enjoyed learning with Incredibles 2 today
And before you watch the scenes without subtitles
and answer some quiz questions,
I want to tell you that I have a bonus
lesson for you over on our Instagram.
So, run over there at "RealLife.English" because I prepared a lesson with the Incredibles family
having just another family moment.
And did you know that you can learn English every day with us?
That's right, every day we have different lessons on all of our channels, podcasts, and Instagram.
Make sure you follow us on Instagram at "RealLife.English" to be informed of the lessons we publish every day. Aww yeah!